Привет! Это последний урок модуля. Давайте быстро пройдёмся по тому, что вы теперь умеете.
За 9 уроков мы прошли полный путь от размытого запроса до котового PRD.
Рекурсивный брифинг, из трёх строчек сделать структурированный бриф, быстрый ресёрч внутри агента и
глубокий через Gemini Deep Research, конкурентный анализ со свод, таблицей фичей и UX паттернами,
аудит конкурента по евристикам Нильсона, три протоперсоны с Jobs To Be Done и конкретными инсайтами,
симуляция интервью, проверили гипотезы до отрисовки, накопали инсайты,
приоритизировали всё по Москву и финал PRD в Notion со всеми артефактами. Каждая техника по
отдельности — это полезный инструмент, но настоящая ценность в другом, когда они связаны в один процесс.
Агент ведёт вас от шага к шагу, и каждый следующий артефакт строится на предыдущих. Это то,
что отличает продуктового дизайнера от рисовальщика экранов. Этот модуль закрывает первую огромную
часть продуктовой работы — стратегию. У вас есть документ, есть обоснование, есть понимание,
что, для кого, зачем вы делаете. Дальше — модуль 2 — System Architect. На всём этом фундаменте мы
начнём строить уже свой продукт. Теперь главное — на этом модуле последнее задание — это курсовой
проект. Чем он отличается от уроков? На каждом уроке мы отрабатывали отдельную технику — брифинг сегодня,
ресерч завтра, персоны послезавтра. По большей части это всё теория, с небольшой долей практики.
Нужно было просто понять метод, как это всё работает. Курсовой проект — это уже применение. Вы берёте
один продукт и проходите с ним все этапы модуля полностью, насквозь и основательно. По-настоящему,
на полной глубине. Если для сдачи домашек было достаточно просто выполнить те действия,
которые были описаны, теперь же мы делаем их уже более вдумчиво, с проработкой и так, как мы делали бы
это на реальном продукте. Итак, восемь шагов: бриф, быстрый ресерч, deep research, конкурентный анализ,
UX audit, персоны, симуляция интервью, приоритизация, PRD — всё то же самое, что в уроках, но в связке и на
полной глубине. Важный момент — на уроках директивы шли как есть, стандартные, под любой проект. В
курсовом проекте вы можете их адаптировать под свой контекст, но желательно адаптировать директивы
под свой контекст процентов хотя бы на 10. Это уже даст большой прирост в результате, поэтому я и давал
вам вот эти вот шаблоны, типы, примеры того, как можно дополнять их. Если продукт FinTech — добавляете в
брифинг и категорию Pro Compliance, если в Медтех в персоны добавляете какую-нибудь медицинскую
специфику. Базовый процесс остаётся, вы докручиваете его под свою задачу. Процесс,
разумеется, остаётся агентским, директивы всё так же выполняют рутину, но теперь мы знаем,
для чего они нужны, как их дорабатывать и имеем общее представление вообще о возможностях агента.
Ваша задача — принимать решения и контролировать качество на каждом шаге. Итак, с каким
продуктом вы будете работать? Тут у нас два варианта на выбор. Первый — это ваш рабочий проект.
Задача с основной работы, фриланса — это самый сильный вариант, если такая задача есть. Вы
сделаете артефакты, которые уйдут в дело и будете работать быстрее, потому что контекст уже у вас в
голове. Второй — это один из продуктов из таблицы, которая будет прикреплена к этому уроку. Там 15
продуктов, которые я отобрал специально под курсовой. Все с понятной бизнес-моделью и серьёзным рынком:
B2B SaaS, FinTech, RecTech, LegalTech, EnterpriseSoft, HellTech,
для клиник, DevTools и так далее. То есть индустрии, где реально крутятся бюджеты.
Мы бы могли делать какое-нибудь приложение для выгула собак, для, я не знаю, чтения, ещё чего-то. Но если мы хотим положить это в портфолио продуктового дизайнера, конечно, потенциально это должен быть продукт, который приносит деньги и в отрасли, в которую вы наверняка захотите пробиться. Поэтому продукты не просты. Не с каждым из них вы знакомы.
С каждым из них вы знакомы. Там есть соответствующие какие-то требования, ограничения, регуляторика, сложные данные, enterprise workflow, нагорелевые сценарии и так далее. То есть это сложные, интересные кейсы, которые в портфолио точно будут на найм работать.
Они покажут, что вы умеете проектировать под бизнес-модель, а не рисуете какое-нибудь приложение для медитаций. Я, конечно, рекомендую вам первый вариант. Если у вас есть реальный кейс, это прекрасно. Но если его нет, смело берите из таблицы, там кейсы хорошие.
Когда вы выбрали, зафиксируйтесь, не перескакивайте между идеями посреди модуля. Смысл курсового в том, чтобы пройти один продукт вглубь, а не три поверхностных. Что мы в итоге сдаём? На выходе одна ссылка, публичная ссылка на PRD в Notion. Больше ничего.
Никаких архивов папок проекта, никаких приложений с отдельными файлами. Почему? Потому что в портфолио вы вряд ли это прикрепите, никто смотреть это не будет.
Да и ни клиенту, ни какому-нибудь лиду вы в дальнейшем всё это показывать не будете. У вас должно быть одно место, где всё визуально, аккуратно, понятно, изложено.
Поэтому и тут, создавая такую среду с реальным продуктом, мы будем готовить именно PRD. Смысл в том, что там всё будет собрано.
Резюме, цели, аудитория, конкуренты, скопы MVP, юзер сториз, риски, родмап и так далее.
И тут есть важный нюанс. На уроке 9 мы собирали PRD в таком демо-режиме.
Он был более компактным, быстрым, удобным, чтобы просто посмотреть принцип, а увидеть, что он структурно действительно всё это делает.
В курсовом PRD должен быть объёмным. Это главный артефакт модуля и он должен выдерживать вес портфолио.
Как этого добиться? Уже ваша задача.
Возвращайтесь к тому, о чём я говорил ранее.
Директивы в курсовой работе вы редактируете под себя.
Поэтому открываем директиву сборки PRD, расширяем шаблон, где было одно предложение, делаем развернутый абзац и так далее.
Но, спойлер, можно попросить агента доработать PRD таким образом, чтобы он более полную картину давал о вашем продукте.
Поэтому тут у вас два пути. Редактировать вручную или привыкать к агентскому процессу и всё перекладывать на него.
И ещё уточнение по поводу проектов с NDA.
Я тут могу только пообещать, что я нигде это публиковать не буду.
Главное, вы отметьте при сдаче домашки, что это под NDA, точно нигде не размещая.
Потому что мы периодически показываем проекты студентов в качестве своего собственного портфолио.
Если же у вас под NDA, вы не хотите оглашать, но хотите заниматься именно им и сдавать его, обязательно укажите, нигде он никогда не всплывёт.
Ну или попросите агента почистить от каких-то пикантных подробностей и так далее.
Это и станет вашим кейсом по модулю.
Готовая проектная документация, которую можно показать в портфолио, отнести клиенту, положить заявку на работу в продуктовую компанию.
Это уже совсем другой уровень, чем просто фигму показывать, там фиг джем, ещё что-то.
На этом первый модуль закрыт.
Вы научились собирать требования, проверять гипотезы, приоритизировать, документировать.
Это основа, без которой визуал потом превращается в красивую обёртку без наполнения.
В следующем модуле переходим к визуалу.
Там ваша работа будет уже оживляться.
Наш PRD мы превратим в дизайн-систему и полноценные макеты.
На этом всё. Удачи с выполнением курсового проекта.
Увидимся в следующем модуле.